[Music]
and as the Sun rises here in Iowa voters
are focusing well on breakfast but then
they're gonna be focusing on today's
historic caucuses let me give you some
of the big picture president Trump won
this state's electoral votes back in
2016 that was only the second time that
a Republican scored a victory here in
the past eight general elections it
happened this way 31 counties that voted
for President Obama in 2012 flipped to
President Trump in 2016 that is the most
of any state in this union we visited
Howard County that's on the Minnesota
border to find out why so many Iowans
swung to mr. Trump and whether they
might swing back for any of the
Democrats running for office
if swing voters are what you're looking
for no County in America swung more
dramatically than this one Howard County
Iowa voted for President Obama by more
than 20 points before a 40 point swing
and a landslide victory for President
Trump all of which raises a question
what happened well what I've been
hearing mainly is that he was an
outsider Laura Huba is chair of the
Democratic Party in Howard County one of
more than 200 counties nationwide that
turned for president Trump in 2016 this
country now Democratic contenders are
hoping those swing voters are willing to
swing back but up here folks get a
little particular
I don't think Howard County is going to
play well for Biden at all because he's
the establishment he's he is the
establishment even though he's knows all
the world leaders and you know I don't
think that means as much as somebody
that's an outsider here Bernie Sanders
is doing well in Iowa but I feel in
Howard County it's still scary there
it's gonna be socialism I don't know how
he'll do in Iowa but up here a moderate
candidate is gonna do well the veterans
calling out bingo numbers at the County
fairground seemed to agree
all three of you voted for Obama in 2012
but it switched the trunk yes and all
three you switch him back that's what's
at stake
all three are leaning toward Pete Buddha
judge or at least leaning away from
President Trump when Trump went to the
office he got rid of all the people I
thought they were gonna help him do what
he needed to do he fired the generals he
said he was smarter than generals we're
all retired military
we're not smarter than generals nearby
the local UAW Union Hall we found
another disaffected Trump voter honestly
what really turned me off and of him was
just the way he is behavior his behavior
like a lot of her neighbors Sarah Burke
is a fan of Peabody Judge I just think
as far as maybe trying to beat Trump we
need to get somebody else in the mix
that wasn't kind of in that mix with the
last election others like farmer Barry
Christensen aren't sure if they'll swing
back and you may go back to the
Democratic Party it's possible he says
he's leaning Republican but not if the
eventual Democratic nominee has a better
plan for agriculture I don't know if
anybody could be certain until you can
evaluate both I'm not gonna say
absolutely no matter who's on the other
side I am or I am NOT going to vote for
Donald Trump you're potentially
persuadable voter absolutely it's a
powerful position to be I hope so yet on
a Friday night in another corner of the
county things look a little different at
Casey dbar 2008 you voted for Obama 2012
Obama again
2016 you voted for Trump yes you know
that they don't really get along right
right
owner Vicki eight tour warns Democrats
may have hurt themselves with all this
impeachment business I think people are
so sick of this and everything that
we're gonna vote him back in no matter
what that's what you're hearing from
people around here yes and you know what
she wasn't lying raise your hand if you
think president Trump is gonna win again
his twenty twenty here and I tell you
what guys Lauren hubba Co we met at the
top of the piece she's the Democratic
party chair she actually agrees with
those folks at the kcd bar she's just
hoping to cut into president Trump's
margin of victory her definition of
success is instead of a 20-point win a
10-point win oh and by the way her pic
as a nominee mayor Pete Buddha judge a
lot of support up there for mayor Pete
Tony yeah yeah it complicates Joe
Biden's message he's the one trying to
pick off those former Trump voters but
Mayor Pete seems to be having some
success it sounds like you you ran into
a lot of potentially persuadable voters
what a great but what a great position
and great power they have at this
particular time a tremendous amount of
power people on the Democrat side they
refer to them as a soon to be former
Republicans it's why it's so fluid still
in Iowa thanks Tony
you